hier les syndicats ont raté leur cours
la France n'était pas à l'arrêt les
trains ont circulé les enfants étaient à
l'école les travailleurs ont travaillé
la France n'était pas à l'arrêt et dire
le contraire serait une contre vérité
certains espérer de grands soir les
lycéens les routiers les salariés du
privé à l'arrivée tout ça fait pschitt
l'objectif des grévistes
les cheminots de Nantes continuent leur
combat de leur côté elles sont des
syndicats c'est qu'ils ont réussi à
mobiliser mais ils n'ont pas réussi à
paralyser les taux de grévistes n'ont
pas été à la hauteur de leurs attentes
effectivement la France n'a pas été
complètement à l'arrêt alors j'ai lu
dans la presse aujourd'hui que c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour le gouvernement moi
je pense surtout que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les Français je disais
hier qu'Emmanuel Macron joue au poker
qu'il avait fait tapis avec une paire de
5 et bien ce matin son bluff a marché
les Français se sont couchés Dominique
tient un bar brasserie dans Abbeville
elle veut continuer la lutte mais ne
pourra pas baisser le rideau aujourd'hui
je vais aller les aider peut-être que je
suis à me réunion de la journée pour
aller sur le rond-point mais je peux pas
me permettre une journée entière de
fermer alors où en sont les blocages la
France compte 200 dépôts pétroliers ce
matin une douzaine était en grève la
plupart provisoirement débloquer ce soir
en revanche dans les 7 raffineries du
pays les expéditions sont à l'arrêt les
carburants ne sortent plus la réforme
est cherche à faire 12 milliards
d'économies par an dans 5 ans si chaque
journée de grève coûte 2 milliards
effectivement ça réduit l'intérêt de
faire la réforme et je dis aussi des
Français se sont couchés et puis arrivé
à rien quoi vous exagérer encore c'est
pour ça que je suis là c'est un projet
d'urgence comptable l'erreur du
gouvernement c'est d'avoir dit c'est
juste c'est un progrès c'est une
formidable réforme non c'est un effort
important qui est demandé aux Français
parce qu'il y en a besoin pour les
finances le silence du président de la
République constitue un grave problème
démocratique voilà ce que dit l'Inter
syndicale est-ce qu'à un moment il faut
pas effectivement qui est une rencontre
avec Emmanuel Macron moi je pense qu'il
y a un temps pour tout la porte du
ministre du Travail Olivier Duster reste
toujours ouverte c'est notre phrase du
jour et les signer les abeilles de borne
et c'est une fin de non-recevoir
adressés aux syndicats qui demandent à
être reçus par Emmanuel Macron lui-même
mais la porte elle est ouverte comment
du gouvernement si c'est votre question
elle est plus couverte en fait nous on
est dans le dialogue moi ce que ce dont
je suis certain c'est que si aujourd'hui
là le président de la République
recevait les syndicats vous trouveriez
les oppositions pour dire regardez il
interfère avec le temps du Parlement il
fait de l'ingérence dans le procès dans
le processus parlementaire et alors que
les débats sont lisaient la majorité
sénatoriale active l'article 38 du
Règlement pour voter plus rapidement
certains amendements c'est le début
d'une longue liste de procédures en
plein milieu de la nuit pour tenter
d'accélérer les débats et de supprimer
plusieurs centaines d'amendements les
groupes de gauche protestent le ton
monte comme rarement au Sénat jusqu'à ce
que les écologistes les socialistes et
les communistes décident tout simplement
de quitter l'hémicycle des milliers de
femmes en colère sont descendus dans la
rue retraites égalité salariale violence
en cette journée internationale des
droits des femmes et les ont crié leur
revendications c'est la journée alors
c'est pas dire la journée des femmes la
journée des droits la journée des femmes
portant un utérus
et quel est le profil qui parle le plus
à 62 ans et qui va donc le plus décalé
de deux ans c'est-à-dire le maximum
c'est les profils de femmes qui ont à la
fois des enfants et une carrière
[Musique]
au gouvernement
je veux aujourd'hui que la force de ce
message
nous aide à changer notre Constitution
afin d'y graver la liberté des femmes à
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse la cérémonie se déroulera
aussi sans la présence d'un défi de
l'avocate le journal Serge alimy qui
dénonce une instrumentalisation
politique en plein mouvement social hier
les députés examinaient un texte pour
rendre inéligible les auteurs de
violence texte porté dans le chahut par
la patronne de la majorité
[Applaudissements]
qui a dit ça Aurore berger invectiver au
bord des larmes la loi est finalement
rejetée
aucune femme dans cette hémicycle n'a
accepté les procès en opportunisme
politique sur la question des violences
aucune femme
je l'instrumentalise pas
[Musique]
parce que Madame au bonheur ça suffit
s'il vous plaît les personnes condamnées
pour avoir frapper leur femme leur
enfant pour violence raciste ou
antisémites sont-elles dignes d'être des
élus de la République demande-t-elle
l'assemblée a donc répondu oui à cette
question en votant contre notre texte
qu'elle cynisme des plantes tels ce
matin
c'est quoi son mari ça compte pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu laisses ta jambe traîner dans l'allée
même si une dame en bleu passe et risque
de se péter la gueule tu laisses ta
jambe tu en as rien à [__]
une femme
pour être un homme après tout d'ailleurs
à l'Assemblée nationale devant un micro
qui fond en larmes et en fait ça
continue les invectives continuent
l'écrit il n'y a pas une once d'humanité
à ce moment-là et même si la dame en
bleu repasse dans l'autre sens tu
laisses ta jambe tu en as rien à [__]